[Applaudissements]
siv ont lancé sa chaussure
je vais le massacre a créé aux assurés
je fais exprès toujours pour mettre
l'adversaire
patricio d'un jour en cinq sets ou pas
en cinq sets excuse moi
stanislas et moi jeu sur le physique
normalement
trois points c'est parti un point pas du
stade il croit qu'il veut me battre à
moi le champion tunisien pakistano turc
peut jouer des heures comme ça mais tu
joues à roland garros
on va toujours dit que mon verre était
mauvais choix qui va battre voulait pas
continuer l'émission
à mon avis on va faire en deux points
sinon il ya des jusqu'à demain je peux
moi je t'explique cela serait pas mal à
[ __ ] je t'aime je m'attendais pour que
kaka
eh ouais
continuer j'en fais j'en appelle à
johnny condamne on s'y attendait pas et
il y encore trois points avril revient
vite parce que trois changements des
règles en plein match pas si je suis
tunisien pas les règlements match c'est
pour que je gagne son poison gagnera 100
points ce matin à l'eysée partie ce
deuxième point il va avoir la honte
devant tous ses copains à roland garros
contre le pac est alors passé comme ça
vas-y que je perds contre un gars coeur
de relancer à vannes on voit qu'ils ont
fait pas les néerlandais passé et oui
c'est vrai que j'ai gagné roland ménard
ça va vite lui ça va mieux
[Applaudissements]
une grande table voit la grande peste
tu abandonnes sur la petite non moi je
veux bien
il ya 2 0 c'est parti à prôner la rade
[Applaudissements]
on a fait les gros alors la numéro trois
mondiale
voilà la grande tablée il parle mais moi
ça me dégoûte freins qui perçoit les
supporter la merde quoi j'imagine pas de
zone on le sait il avait bien un court
de tennis ingénieurs pour le faire
le vent en poupe à 3 078
[Applaudissements]
cette dernière chance au crédit
saint-stanislas d'inhaler ses bras lui
jours merci les chéris vers bonne et
stable
s'il vous plaît patricia ils ont fait un
trou dans le beignet ressent la rue la
rue du grand tennis
on est mieux la raquette
voilà bah là c'est parti c'est énorme en
trois points paraissaient âgées le
soleil c'est drôle on y va aller sans
trois c'est parti roj
ces voix lâchement drôle 1,06 le ballon
plus forts d'inversion marine que pour
celle accomplie
[Musique]
c'est pas terrible et les flics disant
rien mais il protège mais il a pris une
balle de match balle de match pour
stanislas à attention j'ai trouvé une
nouvelle technique
[Applaudissements]
com
les élections c'est notre pierre batut
voilà et la piscine pouvait jouer je
voudrais jouer avec hbo drink